[Music]
Hey everybody, my name is Doug Guthrie.
Uh, I'm a solutions engineer at Brain
Trust. Um, as you can see here, we're an
endto-end developer platform for
building AI products. We do evals. If
you watched the the keynote this
morning, you saw our founding engineer
jumping up and down on stage yelling
evals. I am not going to do that. I'm
not as uh as funny or cool as him, but
uh we should all be very excited about
eval here.
Very brief agenda of of what we'll cover
today in this sort of uh this intro uh
very very brief company overview. Uh
give you an intro to evalu
why would you even uh start thinking
about using them? what are they? Uh what
are the different components that you
need to create an eval? Um some more
brain trust specific things via uh
running evals via our SDK. You'll see uh
in the examples um that you can run
evals both uh in the platform itself as
well as the SDK. I think it's it's a
really kind of cool thing that we can
connect uh maybe the local development
that we're that we're doing with what
we're doing within the platform. Uh and
then how we then move to production. uh
this is uh maybe human review. This is
online scoring. So how well is our our
application performing uh in production
and then lastly a little bit of human in
the loop uh getting user feedback from
your users? How do we now uh take some
of these uh these production logs and
feed them into the data sets that we're
using in our eval uh creating this
really great flywheel effect.
Cool. Quick quick company overview. Um
you see up there maybe in the top right
uh some of our fun excuse me some of our
investors. Uh maybe a quick call out on
the on the leadership side. Anker Goyle
is our CEO. Uh maybe the the reason to
call out that is Anker in the last uh
two two stops. He he essentially built
brain uh brain trust uh from scratch the
last two places. and and this is really
where he found the the idea to like like
maybe this is actually a a thing that
that people need and and really like the
origination story of brain trust. Uh the
other thing to call out here is like we
already have a lot of companies using
brain trust in production today. This is
just a a few of uh the the companies
that are that are utilizing us for for
evals for uh for observability of their
their genai applications.
So, I won't bore you too much with with
that, but uh let's jump into this. If
you're at the keynote, you probably saw
a a similar slide here. I didn't I
didn't take it out, but uh you see like
the tech luminaries here, I think, as as
Manu referenced them talking about evals
and the importance of them. I think this
is a you know, obviously this is an
intro to eval uh track and what better
way to start this out with uh some some
really um you know, influential people
in the space talking about eval and and
why they are so important.
So why would you think about eval?
Right? They they they help you answer
questions. So here's here's a few of
them. Um when I change the underlying
model to my application, is it is it
getting better or is it getting worse?
When I change my prompt, right, when I
change uh certain certain things about
the application, is it getting better or
is it getting worse? So we want to get
away from uh not having a rigorous sort
of process around building with large
language models which as you all know
right non-deterministic outputs uh
creates somewhat of a challenge and
without uh eval becomes really really
hard to uh to create a good application
that we can put into production. Maybe
some other ones like obviously being
able to uh detect regressions within the
within the code. I think the other the
other thing that Anker mentioned uh to
me when I first started which I didn't
really mention this but uh this is my my
third week at at brain trust as a
solutions engineer but one of the things
that he mentioned to me that I thought
really resonated was uh eval are a
really great way I think people think of
them as almost like unit tests for uh
for you know our applications but he
kind of described it another way of like
this is a really great way to for us to
play offense uh as opposed to just
playing defense where I think maybe unit
tests are are kind of used for This can
actually be used as a tool to to really
help uh create a lot of rigor around us
building and developing these
applications and ensuring that we
actually build uh things that we can put
into production.
Maybe from like a business perspective,
uh why would you think about running
evals or using evals? Uh here's a few
here. uh if you have um eval running
both offline and online, you create the
this feedback loop or this flywheel
effect. I think Manu mentioned in the in
the keynote the keynote, excuse me. Um
and this flywheel effect allows us to,
you know, uh cut dev time, allows us to
enhance the quality of this application
that we're putting out in production. If
you're able to connect the things that
are happening in in real life with your
users in production and being able to uh
filter those logs down, add those SP
spans to data sets, inform what you're
doing in an offline way creates uh that
that flywheel effect that becomes really
powerful from a development perspective.
Uh again, a little bit more on the on
the customer side. Here's a few of our
customers and some of the outcomes that
they've that they've seen using brain
trust, whether it's moving a little bit
faster, pushing more AI features into
production or just increasing the
quality of of the applications that they
have. Here's a few of the the outcomes
that we've seen or that they have seen.
So, let's let's start talking a little
bit about the the core concepts of of
brain trust. Obviously, we're here to
talk about evals. uh the the the things
that I think um you see like these arrow
these arrows going uh one way and and
the other this again is that that
flywheel effect that that I described
earlier. Um there's the the prompt
engineering aspect of this uh in brain
trust think of uh this playground that
we have as an IDE for LLM outputs. Uh
the playgrounds allow for that rapid
prototyping as we make those changes as
we change the underlying model. what is
the impact to that to that uh particular
uh task or that application and those
evaluability
aspect right this is the the logs that
we're generating in production the the
ability to uh have a human review those
logs in a really easy uh intuitive
interface and then have user feedback
from actual users be logged into the
application as well
so what is an eval you probably heard
this several several times today
throughout the week if you stop by the
booth. But sort of our definition here
is that structured test that checks how
well your AI system performs, right? It
helps you measure these things that are
important. Quality, reliability, uh
correctness.
So what are the ingredients in an eval?
Right? I've been talking a little bit
about task, right? This is the thing uh
the code or the prompt that we want to
uh evaluate. The the really cool thing
about brain trust is that this can be as
simple as a as a s excuse me a single
prompt or it could be this this full
sort of agentic workflow where we're uh
calling out to tools. There's no sort of
limit onto the the complexity that we
put into this task. The only thing it
requires is an input and an output. The
second thing is a data set. This is our
uh real world examples. This is uh
essentially what we're going to run the
task against to understand how well uh
our application is performing. And how
we do that is via scores. So the score
is really the the logic behind your
eval. There's there's a couple different
ways to think about this. There's the
LLM as a judge type score. So uh you
give it the the output and some criteria
and it is able to assess uh like say I
want uh based on this output is this
excellent, is this fair, is this poor?
And then those outputs then correspond
to you know zero point five or one. Uh
you also have codebased scores right
these are maybe a little bit more
heruristic or binary but uh we can use
both of these to really aid in the
development of that of that eval and
ensuring that we're building a really
good application.
Uh I think I just sort of mentioned this
here as well but like the the two mental
models here of of eval there's there's
offline and online. Offline is
pre-production. This is us actually
doing that that iteration. It's uh
identifying and resolving issues before
deployment. Uh this is where we're
defining those tasks. It's where we're
defining those scores. Uh online evals,
this is that real-time tracing of of the
application in production. It's logging
the model inputs and the outputs uh the
intermediate steps, the tool calls,
everything that's happening. It allows
us to diagnose performance and
reliability issues, latency uh based on
how you instrument your your application
with brain trust. We can pull back lots
of different metrics related to cost and
tokens and duration and all of these
things be help inform uh how we build
this application.
Um I'll I'll jump into a little bit more
of like how we can instrument our app
for online evals. Uh we're going to
first I think talk a little bit more of
the offline
Before doing that, maybe just like level
set on how to improve. I think one of
the the the the things that I've seen uh
in the last few days here, the
conversations that I've had, it's like
almost how do I get started or what do I
do if X or you know those types of
questions. Another thing I had heard
from Anker uh very early on is that like
just get started create that baseline
that you can then iterate and build
from. Uh I think a lot of people get
caught in like creating this this golden
data set of test cases uh that they they
can then like iterate from. Start you
you don't necessarily have to do that.
Start and build that uh that baseline.
Establish that foundation that you can
then improve upon. But this is a really
good sort of matrix of like uh if I have
good output but a low score, what do I
do? Right? Improve your evals. If I have
bad output and a high score, improve
your your evals or your scoring. but
really good kind of like highle uh
understanding of of where to start to
target your your efforts when you are
building these apps and you're and
you're creating evals.
So let's jump into the actual components
that I just that I just talked about. So
within the brain trust platform we have
a task. Uh again this could be a prompt.
This could be like this full agentic
workflow. Uh very basic you see that
that gif running. This is a prompt
within the platform. You uh specify an
underlying model that you want it to
use. You give it a a system prompt. You
can also uh give it access to tools. It
has access to musta mustache templating.
So you can pass in variables like user
questions or um you know the input from
the user or its chat history or
metadata. Right? So when we actually go
and want to parse through these logs,
the metadata becomes actually beneficial
uh enabling us to do that in a really
easy way. Um going forward uh maybe we
have a multi-turn sort of chat type
scenario where we want to add uh
additional messages for the system and
the assistant and the user uh and our
tool calls as well. The uh the the
platform allows for that just via this
uh plus this messages uh button and then
you're able to add those different
messages to the prompt.
Um also we can add tools. So oftentimes
the the prompt will will need access to
to something, right? Maybe it's a a rag
type workflow, maybe it's doing web
search, whatever it is, we can now use
those tools as part of that prompt,
right? And so when you you sort of
encode in that prompt like make sure you
use X tool, uh this prompt has access to
that tool while it's running.
Uh the last one, this is actually a
feature that is in beta right now. uh
it's actually creating more of that
agentic type workflow within your uh
within the brain trust platform itself.
So it's it's a way right now at least to
chain together prompts where the the
output of one now becomes the input of
the other. But if you think back maybe
to to this slide, if I have sort of um
this prompt that has access to tools,
you you create a pretty powerful system
here where you're able to go from uh
maybe that first step that has access to
a certain tool and we get some output
from that. we can then go to that next
step that has access to maybe some other
tools, right? This sort of like maybe
multi- aent type of workflow we can
create with the underlying tools within
those prompts.
The second thing that I talked about is
data sets, right? These are our test
cases that we want to give to the the
task to run. So we can sort of iterate
over that. We can get the output and
then going down a little bit further
actually score that. But this is um
obviously really important when we're
when we're running our eval. And then
when we are uh trying to pull from
production, right, the the actual logs
that are happening, we can add those
those uh spans, those traces to the data
sets in a really easy way. And I can
show you what that looks like. But uh if
you look there at the bottom, the only
thing that's required is the the input.
Uh you also have the ability to add uh
expected. So what is the expected output
for that input, right? you can sort of
like uh create some sort of score that
looks at the output with the expected.
There's a a score called Levvenstein
that allows you to you know measure the
the the difference between those two. So
you can do some different things based
on what you provide to that data set.
You also have metadata as well. Again
being able to filter down different
things pulling the data set maybe into
your own codebase and I want to filter
by again x y or z via the metadata.
That's all possible.
Uh I mentioned this a little bit ago,
but just start small and iterate, right?
You don't have to create this golden
data set to to get started here. Um just
just start and then uh then continue to
iterate and build from that baseline. Uh
the human review portion also becomes
really powerful again when we have stuff
uh being logged within production having
humans actually go through those logs
and you there's lots of different ways
to filter it down to the things that
they should be looking at and then we
can now decide to add those things to
certain data sets that then inform uh
the offline evals that we're running.
Uh the last thing, the last ingredient
here that we need for our excuse me uh
for our evals are our scores. We have
both codebased scores, right? Again,
this is like more of those binary type
conditions, but you can actually uh code
TypeScript or Python. You can do that
within the UI as you see over there on
the bottom left. Or you can within your
own codebase, create that score and then
push it into Brain Trust. So we can use
it in the platform. Other users who
maybe aren't in the codebase can use
that score as well.
The other score that we have access to
is called LLM as a judge. So this allows
us to use an LLM to sort of judge the
output. We can give it the the set of
criteria that indicates what a good or a
fair or a bad score or whatever it is.
You you get to decide uh what that looks
like. So you give it that criteria and
it says if it's good uh I want to do a
one. If it's bad I want to do a zero.
But this starts to create the scores uh
that we can use in that offline in that
online sense. The other thing to call
out here is that we have um internally
built a package called auto evals. So
this is something that you can now pull
into your project. These are out of the
box scores that are both LLM as a judge
as well as codebased. And so it just
allows you to get started very very
quickly. Another thing I heard Anker
mention is um maybe starting with
Levvenstein maybe not the best score in
a lot of cases but again it establishes
a baseline very very little development
work for for uh our users but it creates
that thing that we can then build from
and now you have uh a direction a
direction to go in to go build maybe
that more custom score.
some of the things that we've heard from
our customers. Uh some tips that um you
know important to think about a lot of
our customers are using higher quality
models for scoring. Uh even if the
prompt uses a cheaper model just just
makes a lot of sense like while we're
running that application to use the
cheaper model but use the the more
expensive one to actually go out and
score it. Um also break your scoring
into uh very focused areas. So uh the
example that I'll show is a an
application that that generates a change
log from a series of commits. So I could
create a score that says assess my
accuracy, my formatting and my
correctness. Or I could create three
different scores that assess accuracy
and then formatting and then
correctness. So have your scores be very
targeted to the thing uh that they're
supposed to be doing. Uh test your score
pump, excuse me, prompts in the
playground before use. And then avoid
overloading the score or prompt with
context. Uh focus it on the relevant
input and the output.
Uh a couple things here. Here's where
over on the left we have our
playgrounds. This is where we do that
that sort of like rapid iteration where
we can pull in those prompts. We can
pull in those agents, add our data sets,
and add our scores. and we can click run
and it'll go out and sort of churn
through that data set that we've defined
and will give you a sense for how well
your task is performing against the data
set with the scores that we defined. But
this is the place where uh developers uh
PMs we even have a healthcare company
that has doctors coming into the
platform and interacting with the
playground and even doing human review
as well. Uh depends a little bit
obviously on on the organization. The
thing on the right is our experiments.
This is our sort of like snapshot in
time of those eval. So imagine now like
as we are doing this development and
we're trying to understand uh like the
last you know the last month or so are
are we getting better right the the
changes that we are making the model
changes whatever it is are we improving
our our application and the experiments
is a really great way to to understand
that.
Uh really important maybe to call out as
well. You can see in the bottom right
the eval can happen from uh the
application, right? The the brain trust
platform as well as via the SDK.
Cool. Maybe just really quick because uh
nobody likes looking at at slides all
the time. I I certainly don't. Uh maybe
if you haven't seen brain trust yet,
this is maybe a good a good quick demo.
Uh so again like the the uh the idea
here is I have this this application.
I'll just give you I'll show you over
here. uh you give it a GitHub repository
URL. It uh grabs the most recent commits
and then creates a change log from
there. And then once this completes, you
can even provide some user feedback. But
this is the thing that we want to uh
evaluate.
So what I can do uh I'll go into my my
playground, right? This is the place
where I can start to uh run those those
uh those experiments or I can start to
iterate on that prompt that I have from
my project. I've actually loaded in two
different uh two different prompts. So
maybe I'll before going into the
playground, I've actually created these
two prompts within my codebase and I
pushed them into the brain trust
platform. I've also created a data set
in that codebase and I've also created
some scores. Right? These are the
ingredients that we need to run our
eval.
So now when we have we have those we
have those different components. Now
we're able to start to iterate here. So
I'm going to actually create a net new
playground
and I will load in one of these prompts.
So again, here's my first prompt. Uh my
first prompt has a model associated with
it. What becomes really cool here is the
ability to to like to iterate on the
underlying model, right? I think a lot
of us are we have access to a lot of
underlying providers and we want to be
able to understand if I change this or
if I you know a provider adds a new
model what is the impact to my
application. So I can duplicate this
prompt and maybe change this to GPT41. I
can run this.
Before I run it, I have to add all of my
components. So I'll add my my data set
and then I can add my different scores
that I've uh that I've configured here
for my change log.
And so I can click run and then now
we'll understand here what is the effect
of changing the model uh for this
particular task with the scores that
I've configured against this data set.
So this will churn through all of these
in in parallel and we'll start to get
some results back. Uh lots of different
ways to actually start to look at this
data. I always like coming over to the
summary layout because I can understand
like um you can see over here this is my
base task right here and then my
comparison task. So I can understand uh
looks like you know on average uh the
base is performing a little bit better
than my uh comparison task on my
completeness score. Uh it's fairing a
little bit worse on my accuracy score.
Uh both of them are you know 0% on my
formatting. So probably have some work
to do there. But you can start to see
how you can use this type of interface
to iterate very quickly. Right now uh
the other thing that um maybe shouldn't
do but uh I can't resist because we just
released this today is this new loop
feature. So imagine you are uh you know
you're a user within brain trust and
before this you would sort of manually
iterate here creating net new prompts uh
making modifications changing the model.
What if you could now uh utilize AI to
go and do that for you? So in a sort of
like cursor like uh interface, we can
ask it to optimize a prompt. And I think
the really unique thing here is it has
access to those uh those evaluation
results. And so when it goes to go uh
change that prompt, it understands that
it changes the prompt, it runs the
evaluation. It understands if it got
better relative to the scores that we
defined. So you can see it's going to go
through here. It'll fetch some eval
results. Uh you'll probably see a diff
here very very soon. if we don't I won't
I won't hang out here too long, but I do
want to highlight one of the things that
we are releasing that really enables our
users to iterate in a really uh really
fast way. So, here's my my change. We
can click accept and then it'll actually
go out and run that eval again or it
would uh I think I have an issue with my
anthropic API keys. But the idea here
again is like we can create that very
rapid uh iterative feedback loop here
within the playground.
The other thing here is uh we can run
these as experiments. So this is um this
is where we can start to create those
snapshots in time of that eval and again
see as I make these changes to that that
application how is it sort of performed
over time. I want to make sure I don't I
don't want to go down. I don't want to
like uh decrease the performance of my
scores relative to obviously the last
time it ran, but uh looking out over the
last month, six months, whatever it is
that we're tracking.
Cool.
So that was very very uh brief sort of
intro to like eval via the UI, right?
Again, like just to summarize, we need a
task, we need a data set, and we need at
least one score. We can pull those into
the playground and now we can start to
iterate. We can save these via
experiments. Uh and now we can we have a
way in which we can understand how well
this application is performing. Right?
This is no longer like qualitative,
right? This isn't like hey I think this
got better that output looks better.
There is actual rigor behind this. Now
um customers oftentimes ask though like
I don't really want to use or I'm not
going to use the the platform as much.
I'd rather use this from my my codebase.
Is that possible? uh and it is uh so uh
we have a Python SDK, we have a
TypeScript SDK there there's some other
ones as well. Go, Java, Cotlin. Uh for
the most part, most of our users are
using uh Python or TypeScript. Here's a
just couple examples of what this might
look like from an SDK perspective. Um,
actually, if you all aren't opposed to
looking at uh some code, here's just a a
really basic example of uh defining a
prompt within my my codebase and then
pushing it into brain trust. So, just
leveraging that that Python SDK. Uh,
another example should come over here
creating a score. So, you give it sort
of like the the things that it's looking
for, but now I've sort of defined this
score within my codebase. Uh, it's
version controlled. Uh also the the
prompts that you create within the UI
are version controlled as well. Um but
this is just another way to start to
interact with with brain trust. So again
scores we could do data sets uh and then
you can even do uh prompts up here as
well I believe. So here's my eval data
set. Here's my change log to prompt.
Again being able to start from the
codebase and actually push them into the
platform is possible. Just depends on
the organization where they want to
start.
The the other thing here is like this is
more on the like the components of the
eval side. So that's that top portion.
Define those assets in code. Run that
brain trust push and now you have access
to that in that brain trust library. The
other one is actually like defining the
evals in code, right? So what that looks
like is is slightly different. Um come
over here. So we have our eval
class that's coming from our brain trust
SDK. Again, it's looking for the exact
same things that I just described,
right? A data set that we can use from
Brain Trust itself. Uh the task that we
want to invoke and then the scores. So
again defining this here within uh
within your codebase certainly possible
and then I can run you know a command
that actually runs that eval within
brain trust. So from here go into brain
trust see the eval running this is now
experiment that I can view over time. So
again like you saw two different types
of workflows here uh again catering to
maybe two different personas or again
the way in which organizations want to
work it's up to them. Brain Trust is
very flexible in how we allow our users
to uh to consume or use the platform.
Uh probably jumped ahead a little bit,
but this is sort of a recap of what I
just showed you. Again, from your code,
you you create your prompts, your
scores, your data sets, you can push
them in there. Uh maybe just importantly
important to highlight here of like why
you would do this. Uh you want to source
control your your prompts. Uh the big
one here to call out is the online
scoring. I have a section in a little
bit diving a little bit deeper into
that. Uh but if you want to use those
scores that we define in the data set,
we should push them into brain trust so
that we can create online scores. We can
understand how our application is
performing in production relative to
those scores that we want or that we're
using within our offline evals.
what I just showed you maybe another uh
another variation of that that eval
within our code again defining that data
set defining that task defining those
scores becomes very very easy to now
connect these two things it's just again
up to you to decide where you are where
you want to do this the other thing to
call out here is that this can be run
via CI/CD we do have some customers that
that want to run their eval as part of
the CI process so understanding in a
more automated way right the the score
for A and C whatever they've configured
has it gotten better has it gotten
worse, this becomes maybe a check as
part of CI. There is uh if you look
within our documentation, there's a a
GitHub action example that shows you how
you could set this up.
Cool. Let's let's move to production.
Moving to production entails setting up
logging, right? It entails instrumenting
our application with uh with brain trust
um code. uh being able to like say I
want to wrap this this uh LLM client. I
want to wrap this particular function
when it goes to call that tool becomes
very very easy to do that. But so so why
should you do it? Um I think I've
probably said it said it numerous times
here. But we want to measure quality on
live traffic, right? We actually want to
understand how well our application is
performing with those scores. really
great to use during offline eval becomes
uh our aid in ensuring that we that we
build really good applications that
we're not creating regressions but also
really important to monitor that live
traffic. The other really important
thing to call out I think is that that
flywheel effect that it creates. So we
have these data sets that we use to
inform our offline evals. It's very very
easy now to take the the logs that are
generated within production and add
those back to data sets. This also um
speaks to some of that human review
component where we want to now bring
those humans in. They can start to
review some of the logs that are
relevant like maybe there's user
feedback equals zero, maybe there's a
comment or whatever it is, but like they
can filter down to those particular
things and as they find really
interesting maybe test cases, it's very
very easy to add those uh back to the
data set that we use in our offline
evals. So I think the the feedback loop
or the flywheel effect that that this
creates is one of the really fundamental
value props of of the platform.
So how do we do this? Uh there there's a
couple different ways, right? We're
first going to initialize a logger. This
is just going to authenticate us into
Brain Trust and point us to a project.
Uh you may have seen when I open up the
platform, I had numerous projects inside
of there. You can almost think of a a
project as a as a container for that
feature, right? So you probably have
multiple AI features that you're
building. I want to have a container for
feature A for those prompts, those
scores, those data sets. You could
certainly utilize those things across
projects, but it becomes a really good
sort of way to uh containerize the
things that are important for that
feature. Then you can start really
basic, right? You can wrap a an LLM
client. Uh so when you saw those some of
those metrics with like tokens and l and
duration and costs uh just very
basically within the the uh the script
or excuse me the the code here I just
wrapped that open AAI client and now I'm
just sort of ingesting all of that those
metrics into my logs. That's the easiest
way to get started. You obviously
probably want to uh do a little bit
more. Again maybe you want to uh
understand when you know that LLM
invokes a tool. So, I want to trace uh I
can add a trace decorator on top of a
function. Uh I can even use some of the
like the brain trust low-level like span
elements to create custom logs. And I
want to customize the input and I want
to customize the output and the metadata
that we that we log to that span. So
again, you can you can start very basic
with wrapping in a client and then go
down to like the individual span itself
specifying that input and that output.
This leads us to online scoring, right?
This is I talked a little bit about
this, right? This is where like when our
logs are coming in, we can actually
configure within the platform those
scores that we want to run and we can
specify sort of a sampling rate. So, we
don't necessarily run that score across
every single log that comes in. Maybe
it's 10%, 20%, so on. Um, but it but it
creates that really tight feedback loop
that that I've been talking about. Uh al
also maybe just important to mention the
early regression alerts. So we can
create automations within the brain
trust platform. If my score drops below
a certain threshold, let's create an
alert uh with it with our automation
feature.
This is just uh and I can maybe walk
through what this looks like instead of
showing you here. Uh the custom views.
This is where like there's a lot of
really rich information within these
logs and it becomes really important I
think again for the human review
component to like filter these down to
the things that they care about or the
things that anybody cares about. So we
can create custom views within brain
trust with the appropriate filters uh
and then it's very easy for that human
to go into what we call human review
mode within brain trust and sort of
parse through those logs uh the ones
that are the the ones that are going to
be most meaningful to them.
Let me uh let me connect some of those
those dots there. So
again, showing you some code, maybe
good, maybe bad, but um I'm guessing
there's some technical people in the
room that that don't mind here.
So if I look for um the
uh you may have s seen in one of those
slides, there is a the V vers Versel AI
SDK. I want to wrap this AI SDK model.
Again, this allows us to just create all
of those metrics within brain trust with
just zero lift from us as a developer.
This becomes really easy to do. Uh you
can also see where I have specified that
span itself, right? I actually want to
define the inputs and the outputs of
that. The reason you would do that is
because you have a specific data set
with a structure that you want to ensure
maps to that. So like when you are
within those logs parsing through them
becomes really easy to add those spans
back to that data set. So ensuring that
that data structure is sort of
consistent across offline and online
becomes really important again to create
that feedback loop. So this is you know
very high level of like how we can start
to create those spans.
Um now that we do right we can now go in
uh the platform and start to configure
our online scoring. So this is here just
within this configuration pane I can
click online scoring.
I'll just delete I'll create a new rule.
Uh so my new rule and here's where we
can add different scores, right?
Obviously I have a few here that I've
been using for the offline evals. I
don't necessarily need to select all of
them, but I certainly can.
And then I want to uh apply a sampling
rate. So I want to actually give you an
example of what this looks like. So I'm
going to do 100%. The other thing to
call out here is that you can apply
these to the individual spans themselves
and not the entire root span. So where
this becomes beneficial is like when you
are invoking maybe tool calls, you're
invoking like a a rag workflow and you
actually want to create a score on
whether or not the thing that it gave
back uh is actually relevant to the
user's query. So we can actually create
a score specifically for that and
highlight what that span is here. So
again very very uh flexible in how you
apply these scores to the things that
are happening online.
Now when I come back here to the
application
and we'll just run this again uh
creating that change log
you'll now start to see here within uh
the logs
this will start to show up and then
you'll start to see these scores be
generated. Right? Again, this is where
like you can now start to understand
over time in production. How are these
things doing? How are they fairing?
Where can we get better? Uh again, now
we can connect again like the things
that are happening in our offline evals
with the things that are happening with
online. The other thing to call out here
is the uh the feedback mechanism, right?
Uh we certainly have uh the ability to
do like human review, but oftentimes you
want your users to provide feedback as
well. And so this is just a basic
example of a thumbs up, thumbs down. And
you can even provide a comment here.
This can now be logged to Brain Trust.
So I should see over here my user
feedback. So here's my my comment and
then I have my user feedback score. But
now I can also do something like this.
So again, maybe I want to filter my logs
down to where user feedback is zero. So
click that button. I'm going to change
this to zero.
Right? I don't have any rows yet like
that. But now I can save this as a view
and people who are now using this as
human review can filter this down to
where user feedback equals zero and we
can figure out what's going on, right?
What are the things that that fell down
here within this application that we
need to go fix. The other thing I'll
highlight here is our sort of human
review component. Uh actually
um you click that that button or you can
hit just R and it opens up this this
different pane of your log. So it's a
paired down version of what you just saw
there. It's a little bit easier for a
human to go through and actually uh look
at that that that input and that output.
But you as a as a user of Brain Trust
can configure the human review scores
that you would like to uh to use. So I
have this add something here. So maybe
this is a little bit more free text. I
have a better score. Again, these are
the things that that you can add to your
platform that map to the the the review,
excuse me, the scores that you want your
your humans to to add to those logs.
Um, just really quick, I I'll highlight
some of these things here. Um, this is
what it starts to look like when you
instrument your uh your application with
those different um wrappers or those
different trace functions. uh I'm able
to understand at a very granular level,
excuse me, granular level the things
that it's doing, right? So I essentially
have these tool calls where it's going
out and it's grabbing the commits from
GitHub. It's understanding what the
latest release is and it's fetching the
commits from that latest release and now
I can generate that change log. But
again, the the really unique thing here
and maybe a different example of this
is I can start to score those individual
things that are happening. So this is a
different uh application with a
with this example. So if I open this up,
I have these uh this conversational
analytics application. So a user can ask
a question, it can return back some
data. But this application goes through
these various steps, right? The first
step is to rephrase the question that
the user asked. So imagine like there's
this chat history that we can load in as
input and the LLM needs to rephrase that
user question. If the LLM does a really
bad job of rephrasing this question,
everything as a result of this will fall
down. probably not going to get a right
a right answer. So what I can do is
create a score specifically for that
span to understand how well the LLM did
in rephrasing that question can also
understand the intent that I was able to
derive or the LLM was able to derive
from that question. Is that right? But
you start to think of like these these
more complex type of applications that
you build. You need to be able to
understand the individual steps that are
happening and brain trust allows for
that very very easily via these scores
and then being able to apply them not
only again while you're in offline eval
kind of mode but also online right we
want to uh understand these logs and be
able to apply these scores at the
individual span level this becomes
pretty powerful as well.
Um, I think I actually stole from my my
next section,
my human in the loop. Kind of walked
through this uh a little bit. Um, maybe
just another call out if you happen to
be at one of our workshops on Tuesday,
um, Sarah from Notion, uh, who's a a
Brain Trust customer talked a little bit
about how they think about human in the
loop. And I think it's it's important to
consider like the the size of her
organization and what they're doing. Um,
she mentioned that like she has a
special type of role that they use for
human in the loop type of interaction,
right? There is it's almost like a
product manager mixed with an LLM
specialist. Uh, they're the people that
are going through and doing those human
reviews. Smaller organizations, she made
a comment that was it actually makes a
lot of sense for the engineers, some
engineers to actually go through and do
this as well. Becomes really powerful to
pair like the automation with the human
component of this. like this is not
going to go away. I think it it adds
value to the process.
Um
again, I think I just stole from myself
like why why this matters, right? This
is really critical for the the quality
and the reliability of your application.
Uh it provides that that ground truth
for for what you're for what you're
doing.
Two types of human in the loop uh
interactions here. I walked you through
that human review. Um give me one second
and I'll call you. Yeah. uh the the two
excuse me the two types the human review
uh being able to like create that that
uh interface within brain trust that
allows that user to kind of parse
through the logs in a really easy manner
as well as configuring scores that allow
them to add the relevant scores to that
particular log and then the user
feedback. This is actually coming from
our users in the application. Again
being able to create sort of uh views on
top of that feedback that then power uh
maybe the human review and then creates
that flywheel effect uh that we that we
that we want.
That's all I have today. Appreciate you
all coming out here and and listening to
me. But yeah, you had a question.
Thanks.
Yeah, the question is around like how
are we using uh human review and like
some of the logs and informing the the
offline eval portion of this largely
that cool uh yeah one thing I maybe I
didn't highlight here is so maybe back
within brain trust
I'm going to go back to my initial
project.
So imagine now like we have we have all
of these logs. We filtered it down to a
particular Oh,
are we still showing
on the screen?
Awesome. Thank you. Um, yeah. So,
imagine like we have this uh this this
process now, right, where we're we're
doing that human review. We filtered it
down to the records that are meaningful
for whatever reason. It becomes really
easy again to connect what's happening
within production. So, I maybe I select
all of these rows or I select individual
rows, but I can add these back to the
data set that we're using within those
offline evals. I I think I've said this
like a hundred times over this
conference, this flywheel effect. This
is like I think what's missing
oftentimes when we're building these
these AI applications and what brain
trust allows for really seamlessly.
Yeah. Uh I have two questions. Uh the
first one is about production. Uh is it
possible to have multiple models in
production and compare how they behave?
Yeah, I I don't see why not. Like my
guess is in the underlying application
you're swapping them out
like having like AB tests, you know, I
can have like a two or three or four and
easily compare. Absolutely. Yeah. Um
let's see if I have an example here.
You're able to to group some of these
scores. Uh maybe this is sort of an
example of of what you're talking about.
So like maybe within production we have
different models running. uh this this
sort of view here allows us to
understand like the the models that
we're using under the hood. Uh and this
is just you know you could do this
within production as well and sort of do
that AB testing. Cool. Uh my my second
question is about humans in the loop,
right? Um
let's suppose that I have multiple
humans and um they behave uh slightly
different as a scorer scorers. Do you
have anything or what what is the vision
to do with that? Like is there a way
that I can actually compare how they're
scoring or something like that or not
really?
So different users can maybe have
different sort of criteria for scoring.
Maybe the first thing I would say to
that is like there there should be like
maybe a rubric for your users who are
interacting with human review. So you're
not creating that. Uh you certainly have
the ability to see like who is scoring
different things within the platform.
Um, I'm not sure if you're able to pull
that as like a data set to like assess
the differences there, but maybe like
before it gets to that place, like have
a rubric, have a guideline of of what
scoring looks like for your humans.
Okay. Thank you. Yeah, of course.
Hi. Um, so the scorers I'm used to
working with for like LLM as a judge are
like they're relativistic, right? So
they can't tell you is the answer
relevancy good or bad for a single run
but it can tell you how it compares to
previous iteration of like the same test
set for example.
Um, do you guys use LM as a judge scores
for online
or is and like
how are are they relativistic like that
or do you have some way to be like this
is a good answer you know in and of
itself for this sample or because it's
all you have new data coming in right
yeah I think a lot of our customers who
are are thinking about this are like
almost doing eval
like trying to understand did the LLM as
a judge actually do a good job there. So
like when that actually runs there's a
rationale behind it and so you can sort
of run an eval of those LLMs as a judge.
I think Sarah from notion in our
workshop described sort of a process
like that within notion but I think
that's that's sort of like where I would
aim you. Okay. Cool. Thanks. Cool.
Awesome.
Are any of your customers doing eval
before they launch? Like I'm working
with a government.
They don't want to launch until we show
some accuracy levels. Yeah. So, we're
getting our subject matter experts to
enter in all the questions that they
have. Right. They have huge data sets of
thousands of questions, believe me, as a
government. Um,
and then we're using measures like
you're talking about.
Do you have a way to do that? Like I
guess it I guess it's the same is it? So
what you're describing is what we call
offline evals, right? This is
development, right? Um, we can actually
do this testing before we get into
production. And this is what I was
talking about like establish that
baseline, right? Using those scores,
using that that data set that you've
already um created, but this all happens
before we get into production, right?
And then you can like one of the things
that I heard from from somebody earlier
is like one of my challenging things of
building this AI application is uh
establishing trust or creating that
trust in this thing. That's part of what
this is, right? It's like it's showing
showing uh those people the scores of
that application. So you start to
iterate on this thing. Maybe it starts
at 20% then it goes to 30 then at 40 and
so on. That to me is the thing that you
use to create that trust and uh create
that like ground swell to push it into
production. Okay. Yeah, that's what it
that is what we're trying to do. So but
I wondered if I can see the tool does
that. Thank you. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
Time for one more. Thanks. Um quick
question. I love the CI/CD components.
Um we're trying to build a lot of um
we're trying to build like ML as a as a
platform for our team. Um so we're get
into evals and stuff like that. So how
much of how much of the monitoring
dashboard you have in brain trust can
actually be like take the data taken out
and posted in a unified dashboard
somewhere else. Yeah. All of this is
available via SDK, right? You can pull
down experiments, you can pull down data
sets. Uh so you're able to you know pull
this down like we have we have a
customer that is actually building their
own UI on top of like the the SDK
itself. Like so they built their own
sort of like components utilizing the
SDK and pulling the the sort of things
that we've logged the experiments that
we have in the application into into
their own UI. So certainly possible.
Awesome. Oh great. Thanks. All right.
Cool. Thanks everybody.
[Applause]
[Music]